[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
kiwitalks my guest today was a former
writer at valve for over 12 years
he is now the ceo and co-founder of
stray bombay
and currently working on a game a
necrosis
anachrosis my apologies i know that
naming things are hard
yeah yeah yeah as only after eric
actually said that he liked the name
that i was comfortable that would do a
weird name
so hello
you want people that people that
something they can pronounce and they
can
they know how to spell it and like right
it's all of that but equally
it's like worse 70s sci-fi game right
and so
um sci-fi in particular has so many
titles taken from all the pulp fiction
day of pulp science fiction days right
we're right you know light years away
and every galaxy something's been taken
so we just wanted a strange word but
yeah it was familiar and it's in the
dictionary so
oh is it because i've never even
the beats before song starts it's like
the little little bit lead in which kind
of match all right which there is a
dance band british dance band
that had a song
faded flowers
that i really liked
and it had the line um this is dana
cruz's domain the main uh fight remains
or something like that um yeah
and so that was that was the the impetus
for it but yeah yeah
so
as a writer do you read the dictionary a
lot to try and learn big words
no
oh except um
i have the big dictionary of slang
which is
they they only do the first two volumes
so it's like a through f and f through o
or something and that's a good book just
to randomly grab um words from
uh-huh
no a hundred years ago i took 12 years
of classical music so um i that's where
i know it from right but but but the big
book of uh the big book of slang is a
really good book i mean i mean it's
american slang so
you'll get less value out of it maybe
but it's it's pretty funny
but wouldn't it's a serious document to
be clear it's not a joke book is a
serious like etymology of
slang
but doesn't slang evolve over time so
wouldn't it become
obsolete after sure some of the words
would be and it doesn't have a bunch of
the words that needs to be in there
remember that's kind of all dictionaries
right but it's a capture of time
right okay so do you try and stay up
with
new slang
no no
you're beyond that point
i have no idea what the kids are talking
about when i see um
a couple like when i see three letters
in a text i often have to go search to
see like oh okay yeah all right
i know like i know you're you're on your
way i know that one
but like right there's a lot of just uh
i have no idea what anyone's talking
about half the time which i've never
have so that's okay um
so do so your name chit fella sick does
it have any meaning like your surname
because it's an interesting surname
well no so um
my family is polish
right so you would really pronounce well
and when they're coming over they
americanize the name
so really it's phil jackie
um
would be
and there is actually a couple like
still in poland um but yeah so uh it
we just say falasak my sis one sister
actually removes the z in her business
card just so people can pronounce cds
here because z scares them but you feel
sick
oh okay
yeah
interesting
so how many how many people actually
know that
by james
well yeah do they know that about your
surname or any people close to you you
know i don't i don't think so the the
decide to have the one the one advantage
of all of it is that um i have a unique
name so if i smash my name together and
i go on twitter i know that name's gonna
be there there's somebody impersonating
me
which is both good and bad because that
means um
my mother is still alive she could um
search on google for me
and anything she found was was me um
which
yeah there's there's there
there's some things i had to explain to
her
[Music]
i wanted to ask you about your
your first day at valve or being
approached by gabe because it was it was
it was quite random it came out of the
blue wasn't it was an email or a phone
call
no so um
me and eric had stopped updating um old
man murray back yeah that was the
website we had that's right and then one
day eric called me he's like check your
email check your email i'm like i'm
checking my emails like no no no go
because we had stopped checking your
emails because they're just filled with
spam right so you know i checked the old
man murray email and i'm like oh
it's a email from gabe saying you know
you want to come to valve
and we're like can you explain more and
he's like nope just come on out here so
is he is he a blunt guy
in terms of in terms of that aspect just
like no you're not gonna i'm not gonna
tell you information you have to come
here first well so later i would learn
especially an email um he's very very
much like you could you could lay out a
budget for five million dollars on
something and be all detailed and his
response would just be yes
right like there's there's no discussion
about it um it's it's both good and bad
i got really used to it and now i
as somebody who runs a company i've been
told that often i'm too cryptic
and i need to
be more verbose so people can understand
the contextual rising around it but for
me and gabe it was great i loved that
quick and short and also the man answers
a gazillion emails a day right
and he actually answers all of them and
so
to do that the only way you can do that
i think is being super cryptic so yeah
no he was he's super straightforward on
that
so
yeah so
we then flew out to the seattle
and
you thought you were going to get fired
after the first day didn't you
well we had no idea what we were doing
um
they had i think i don't know i can't
remember what eric's covered out so i'll
just recover
there was a different group inside of
uh um valve that was doing some more
narrative kind of based stuff and that's
like they weren't sure if they should
hire us directly into that or over in
the valve and they went you know just
hired us in the valve but working with
that group
and it was like the first day we got the
hey this is kind of the story idea
and i think
i can't remember now if we woke up and
did it in the morning or we stayed up
that night but we rewrote the whole
thing we created like a two-hour movie
on our first day and they're just like
they're like wow that's a lot of work um
yeah this is like two hours worth of
content we're not going to do this and
we're like oh god we have no idea what
we're doing we're just being idiots
uh it was pretty funny still though uh i
i yeah eric cracks me up so anytime i
can i can push him to write something is
a good day because that means that i'm
going to be laughing
and that was definitely is funny but um
yeah not something they use
because what's the push and pull aspect
between you two the dynamic that you
have
so is he trying to do the same to you as
to what you do to him in terms of trying
to
promote something funny to come out of
him
i don't know if it's ever that
thought out per se um i mean definitely
like in the old man murray days when we
were sitting next to each other in an
office where the only thing was trying
to get each other to laugh i mean
sometimes
i'm less of a writer room writer
i very much more like to go dwell on
stuff and so a lot of times you'd just
be getting really wound up
the night before because
on that website i was like the lunk head
kind of crazy angry dude and it's hard
to do that some days like you kind of
get to get yourself wound up
uh to really just be incoherently raging
um and so
like to do that would be on my own but
then he would see it that you know that
day and be like oh this is awesome yeah
i'm gonna do this with this or whatever
and so yeah
ah and was there a
much weight of expectation in terms of
doing half-life 2 because mark laidlaw
laid such a
great groundwork i suppose for you guys
so you should come in here and try and
meet the expectation
well so originally remember we're going
to write for the we weren't even going
to write for the game stuff at that
point it was going to be for this
narrative stuff that lived in the
half-life universe and mark was super
open and supportive and then we talked
with mark a bunch before then right um
and so he had always been and there's
actually a group of people um
like bill van buren and bill fletcher
who had also contributed kind of to the
story and stuff and they were all super
welcoming and great and just being like
don't know how this is going to work out
but let's just talk and figure it out
and so you know that was
that was super helpful
in terms of what happened
wait oh sorry i didn't answer your
question so to answer your original
question there was no way because we
were doing our stuff and we didn't ever
think it was gonna see the light of day
so what did it matter yeah yeah fair
enough in terms of uh left for dead
because i find with zombie stuff is
you're
you're kind of confined to a certain
cliche was
with any type of zombie narrative right
you have to have a virus an outbreak of
some kind and all those people so when
you were writing left for dead
um was it ever challenging to try and
think of some original concept
well so not really because at the time i
mean
at the time
you know there that once i went to
dinner with gabe and he was beating me
up that um
if you look at zombie movies he's like
night of the living dead's about racism
day of the dead's about uh or donna the
dead's about consumerism
um like
these
uh what's his face that purposely made
those movies about things and kind of
like to talk about them and he's like
you know what is what is your movie
about
you know what is your game about what's
your zombie story about and i'm like
well you know it's about
working together it's it's the game
itself it's the reflection of the game
of you know in the zombie apocalypse
what are you going to do
and then
you know it would kind of get pushed
more and more because i remember he's
just like well let's not do zombies
zombies are zombies are just cheesy
right they're just really cheesy and at
the time you do not have like the
walking dead tv series and all this
right so
it was very cheesy
but as a kid who saw don of the dead at
a midnight movie and was just like
terrified
um it wasn't cheesy to me
i had no idea those scenes were cheesy
until like watching them later you're
like oh yeah man that is that is camp
um so it's just like well why don't we
just take the characters in the world
don't they characters in the world some
of the characters in the world are aware
that they're in a zombie movie
essentially right like um zoey and lewis
understand that like oh my god this is
the thing of movies
um but they play it seriously and they
take it seriously and it's kind of like
uh just the anachrosis we do the same
thing as like early
70s late 60s sci-fi is very campy very
cheesy
but if you just take that as serious and
you have those characters inhabit that
world and play it for the serious then
it just has a different feel to it and i
think you transcend that campiness and
cheesiness
right
but did the story stay pretty much the
same from the get-go or was it
constantly changing
throughout
um
so one of the things i'd like to do for
something like that is there's a whole
back story that we've never shared out
that goes on like where it got formed
and how it propagated originally and all
of this
because that's just in the background so
that when you're talking about something
you have that laying behind you but
since and this is a really important
thing for me is since it wasn't
anybody's virus it wasn't like zoe's
virus like zoey wasn't like i caused
this virus now i need to go save
everybody instead they were just caught
up like you would be caught up in it
that information didn't always have to
be correct or line up to that because
clearly we've seen uh in modern day uh
this information sometimes is purposely
done and sometimes it's just done
because you're using shorthand or you're
excited or whatever and so really wanted
to play with that so never surfacing
what that underlying was but having that
underpinning and that stayed the same
um the why they didn't get it and the
[Music]
um you know and some of like that kind
of thing i think
probably got tightened up over time like
we thought oh this is the device we can
use now like
you know why because we always had this
like why aren't they dying but it
literally wasn't until like left 4 dead
2 there was like this really clear thing
of like hey you're you can't be infected
you're immune to it and what that means
and so like the final chopper scene
you're talking to the chopper pilot like
there's this is being told i think for
the first time in the game probably and
that then becomes in the comic book and
we take it everywhere else but that's
that was there but we just hadn't really
ever used it
and once you use something and you start
talking about it that's then when you
start getting kind of more information
on it you kind of
internally
start having a better understanding of
what it is
yeah
yeah that does make sense but with
everything that we've lived through in
terms of covert
if you could go back and redo
the the story would that
would you do it differently based on
living through an actual virus obviously
without zombies but
well there'd be more masks
um
there would be yeah you know i think
some of the probably the language that
we would put into the world would have
been different but the
overall not really because i still think
you know you see that i think
if you look at life so like
the original left 4 dead
um
that world is really one of a lot of not
knowing at all and we're we're really
kind of
lost entirely and then left 4 dead 2 we
kind of start with essentially fema we
end with the military and that was like
kind of like trying to show the
different
possible responses and i mean i think if
if this virus had been more contagious
and more deadly
um
you know would it have turned into the
kind of the military thing i think you
could start seeing where it could have
right you could see the raising of
tensions you could see
the anger you could see the weird
being a patriot for wearing a mask and
being a patriot for not wearing a mask
and how divisive people were and like
all that stuff i think you see over time
coming out so i think we would
definitely have played into that
um but i still think the the overall
kind of
how it went
work pretty well
yeah
so when you're writing a story in the
back of your mind are you thinking about
the possibility of it leading into a
sequel
like with a with a game franchise
whether it was half-life or portal or
left for dead or you just focus on the
game being a complete package
or
is there little easter eggs possibly
that you you're thinking where you could
take it
so so the original left 4 dead
definitely did not have the
it both had not thinking of the sequel
and not tying it up into a typo
of
where they were going except the idea
that maybe if they were landing in the
military that you felt better about that
but then of course
we see in the comic and stuff it was
definitely then through the dlc that
followed it that we started to be like
okay let's map this out like this is the
interesting way to go
this is what can happen
at that point we also knew left 4 dead 2
we wanted to follow a second set of
survivors
and then
we wanted to have them meet up because
think about like all the npcs you meet
in the world you have no backstory on
them you have no understanding so what
would it be like to meet nbc's that you
actually knew
and you had this backstory to them like
you don't get to do that very often and
so that was a fun thing and like that
was planned out a little bit
and then
we had really been talking about for a
while
at the company um about
uh you know killing
killing characters and what that's like
right and so obviously spoiler in the
half-life two episode two if you get to
the end someone doesn't make it um but
uh
you know we want to do the same kind of
thing in left 4 dead where there was
something and um
we were trying to figure out the best
way to do it and actually escape who was
just like you should kill the character
you like the most
um because that will resonate the most i
mean that was a shorthand it's more
complex
better said
uh and so for bill to me for for me bill
was uh
a character i really loved a lot of his
lines are
eric knows my father and my uncle
um
and
they speak alike and they speak a lot
like bill like the go pound salt and all
of those kind of things are like you
know lines my dad would yell so so we
killed bill
um and so like we have those kind of
things understood and set and kind of
they're like
laid out a little bit but a lot of it
others just as you're doing it and
going um you just take it from there and
i mean as with anything uh they get in
the helicopter they get in the plane
they get in the
atv they get in the military vehicle
that doesn't mean they got safe right
like
those games are always like all we need
to do is go up this elevator oh the
elevators out all we need to do is right
and so it's you can always i think i
think players are comfortable with that
um
so out of all the games that you wrote
for
at valve was there a particular one that
was the most challenging
most challenging
maybe you just found it hard to write
the story or the dialogue or
well um
so
challenges there's two ways it was
challenging one was um so portal 2
i did the co-op
and i didn't want to work on portal 2
because at that point i had worked on
episode 1 orange box so that you know
all of everything in there left for dead
one left for it to i just wanted some
time off
and so i would just kick around with jay
and eric but they did
the
the single player story and they were
doing a
co-op you know the co-op side as well
right and they'd gotten behind on it and
it kind of got into a weird spot
and
uh uh they're like hey can you meet i
think it's like like can you meet monday
and i'm like oh sure sure and then i'm
like hey i can't meet monday i gotta go
to the vet
found out my cat had cancer like cats my
my company's name and after cats stray
bombays bombays are breeding cats
um and so i was like oh this sucks
and so i came in the next day and
they're like hey can you just do the
co-op
uh story i'm like i am not in the mood
to be funny or wanting to do this at all
and it was the best therapy because it
was pretty much a week of uh
just sitting in a room and cracking me
up uh jay and eric are both hilarious so
it was like the best therapy and then we
just made the we just made the agreement
we would share what we were working with
each other but we would never
comment like we would never be like
like we knew that they wouldn't be the
exact same they would be their own thing
so that's fine we're not gonna get
caught up that they're a little bit
different than each other right
yeah
so glados is slightly different and
she's talking to a robot so it makes
sense she's slightly different right and
yeah the whole thing was i would only do
it if i could if i could
the end joke that i had in my head um
would be okay is the ending and that was
that
essentially you're leading these two
robots to kill the remainder people on
earth
and so as you know armageddon was was
the payoff for the for the game and was
that always
was that that's comedy gold man yes
examination
if it's done right
um was that always set in stone though
or did it change a lot because i know
with the actual uh single player with
portal two
um they obviously a lot of the design
kept changing so then they'd have to go
back and rework that was that was the
first thing that was the first that was
the first thing that was set in stone
then it was like how do we get there and
that's you know if you remember you find
the disks yeah um and that came and then
it became how do we think of these
different tracks and then i went and did
research on like um training and like
essentially they're all different
training tracks but like mental training
tracks so some are about confusion some
about like
i don't remember god this many years
later exactly what they all were but it
was like i i'd use this idea of theming
them um that way
right and then then that worked and then
both you know left for dead one and two
were just
both hard for um i was also the project
lead on that so spending just a lot of
time on the game itself let alone the
writing
and that just
is a lot of time and a lot of um
a lot of work and sometimes that would
be hard and a lot of those
a lot of that game
especially i think two probably more
than even one
is
me sitting in a hotel room drinking beer
writing the night before a recording
session or like
getting jay and eric also wrote on those
as well right and so like i try to
formulate all of those but there'd be
just a bunch of like
they're working on other stuff they
don't know the
hey we created this new thing and now we
we have melee weapons and now we need to
create all these melee combat lines or
whatever right so they don't know that
they can tell the story stuff but that
other stuff like i just need to go do
and so i'd just be sitting in a hotel
room like the night before just pumping
that out and the actors would be you
know asking when they get their scripts
and be like the day before are you crazy
um well the thing is because you do
mention it but obviously you are a
writer but you wore a lot of hats at
valve you weren't just a writer right
but yeah was that always the case
did you always
know that that was going to be the case
that you're going to end up
doing a lot of different work or did you
was it sold to you or pitched by gabe
that like hey you're just going to be a
writer
i know so early like i think our second
day they're like they're like just walk
down the hall and do whatever you want
and you'll make everything better and
you're like that's that's crazy talk
these are really smart people here ah
but i mean they kind of mean it
um and so like the very first thing i
did at valve was i complained i really
liked the game david defeat source we
were play testing internally i'm like
the website sucks
and uh greg coomer's just like well why
don't you just go do the website then
and so with q uh the graphic designer we
just redid the website
um
so
yeah during the orange box um
the playstation was being done kind of
out of house the um
xbox has been done in-house and i was
the first person who was like playing
the full if you remember it also had
like half life in it and half a half two
in it and everything else so the first
person playing through that on the xbox
and playing like uh
a bunch of that stuff
uh and i realized that we just were not
gonna hit q a like we had no idea what
certification was and like oh my god
were we failing and like like every like
i was playing at the qa manual like
certification manually like we were
failing everything
so i went with john morello one of the
animators and we're both like we've got
to fix this and so we just took over qa
and essentially um grabbed everybody's
dev kit out of their offices put them in
the hallway
and started running this qa process
because morello was super
i am not detail-oriented i i can try all
my life i never will be he was and so
together we just kind of created this
kind of testing plan i mean that's not
right like
that's to me that's the fun thing at
valve you see a problem
you act like it's your company and how
do you solve this well i'm just going to
go do this and
i mean
the orange box yeah we i i
did not help with crunch i i made it
worse uh because we were just having
people testing 24 7. it was just like
out in the hallways
food carts food being brought over like
it was
it was a bit crunchy it wasn't
forever like it wasn't like bong but
like to get it out the door that was
very um
crunchy and very much needed that focus
but it was also the fun thing because
you know you saw everybody pulling
together and working together as a team
and
understanding you know like hey we can't
just all keep playing um tf2 against
each other
we have to test these other games and
yeah
yeah so i've always done a lot of
different things there like i mean i
wouldn't did biz dev with vr and
i worked with developers on that as well
and stuff so yeah i like i like that you
can mix up your job like that so have
you tried to keep the same sort of
work culture as valve at stray bombay
because obviously valve has a very
unorthodox approach in terms of its
development
so valve doesn't crunch valve doesn't
crunch or crunch like we used to at
least um so i i don't think so i mean i
think it was influenced by that but
there's a different scale right there's
a different way you have to think about
your company at 350 then you have a 20.
you know
even like the flat hierarchy worked
really well on like episode one
where the flat hierarchy didn't work
well when we had three teams doing
different things right like you started
needing to have leads be a little bit
more prominent
excuse me um
so like that's always been there and for
for but the underlying idea is
that the person who is best to solve the
problem who understands it the best and
working on it is the one doing the work
and deciding the work versus having like
a designer sitting on top just
generating a bunch of paper designs and
making engineers go off and do it
it's more of a collaborative process
with that and so we definitely at stray
bombay have that as well
we don't have dedicated designers
everybody is part of the process i mean
there's people
the guy ryan does the the metagame and
he designed the metagame but he's also
implementing some of it as well as
coming up with crazy weapons and stuff
and so
i always think if somebody's really
passionate and excited you don't know
how that expresses itself and it doesn't
always express itself in their craft
exactly and sometimes that just may be
an idea it might be a really good idea
and you just want to capture that idea
and make sure it's there right
and so it's like when we were writing
even for the portal series it'd always
be like hey we're going to go off and
record a bunch of stuff does anybody
have things we should be putting in here
like does anyone have ideas like
always take those ideas and steal them
and make them your own um but like right
but like you should always be
collaborative that way and i think
that's the strength of
like kind of that valve process i think
people get caught up in the flat and
the handbook and
like there's a lot of
garbage around it that isn't helpful but
that idea of just the people doing the
work are kind of in charge of the work
and are able to make their own decisions
is an important part of it and that's
that's what scales and inside of the
teams that scales and that works and
that's what we try to do as well
i mean i've spoken to a lot of divs now
from a lot of different companies and it
seems like
narratives online uh
crap that it's not truthful at all but i
mean you must have read stuff over the
years about misperceptions at valve and
how things are viewed within the company
that yes obviously haven't even
transpired and that there's you know
there's some
something ridiculous it's like you know
one of them is like our valve is doesn't
like to make
games with the number three in it and
they don't do anything you know all they
do is work on steam which is obviously
not the case
but um if
if there's one misperception about valve
that you would correct what would it be
well i guess it's also part of the
process it's the thing that people get
wrong about the process and it takes a
long time to before it sinks into you
and it's not that um there are no
managers
it's that everybody's your manager
and so we're going to go ship left 4
dead 1 and an engineer comes up to me is
like i think we really should package
these as groups of four we should never
sell the game solo it's only fun with
your friends um that's the only way this
game's ever gonna be successful
okay he has a valid argument that he's
making
he's
making it from a point of a bunch of
information he has talking about other
examples and everything else and then i
have to be able to respond i can't just
be like well off you know right
like
you can say that it's fine
right like you can't just say that you
have to be like okay you have to take
that in and go okay
and so then with that is
everybody can give you information
everyone gave you feedback everyone gave
you information but that does not mean
you need to act on it what you need to
do is go okay why are they saying this
what is their worry what is their
concern or is there a valid point here
or are they right
right and i think i mean definitely as
i've gotten older i've gotten just way
more comfortable with realizing how
little i know
um i think during various parts of my
life i've thought i've known more than i
have and
sometimes that sometimes it works for
you right and sometimes it doesn't um
but it's it's there in the the best the
best version of valve has that
collaboration where you're being
challenged all the time and you're being
challenged in a valid way
right so
like gabe with the story right i mean
gabe is
not yelling at me but he is he is
confronting me in a restaurant that
there is no story and how can we make a
game with no story and this is going to
be like a disaster and if he if i don't
come up with a story he's going to come
up with a story he came up the story you
know i know his story like like he's
just pushing and then like a week later
he's doing an interview on some german
tv thing and he's repeating the words
that i said
and it's just like okay
he will accept that we disagree
because i've i've valid to him
defended my position and the reason why
we want to do this
and so
you had to be able to do that this is
about communication and that's why you
know like communication is always like
the best thing to hire for because
somebody can talk about the problem and
communicate and communicate
with their with their version of what
they're seeing to it
it's just a hundred times better it's
when you don't have that communication
and people are just making shots in the
dark and you have no input into it and
they have no input to you is when you
fail and so as long as you have that
communication and you have that respect
for each other to be able to say okay i
disagree but
yeah let's go that way like that that's
then when it's magical
but how do you deal with that in the
case of creatives because creatives tend
to be a bit more sensitive and take
things personally or they can do
i mean i know i do at times but i think
i'm a lot better than i used to be but
obviously um if you tell somebody that
their work sucks or
even if you worded in a better way some
people can be very sensitive to that
yeah first um i think this is one reason
why i think sometimes it's easier to
work with artists because they've done
this process before when they've been
through school if they have a form if
they've been formally trained they've
gone through school and they've done
reviews and they've gotten those
critiques where it is brutal to their
soul
yet they know that person's right or
they learn how to deal with it
um and i mean some part of like that's
one reason why sometimes some people
don't fit in right is a hard thing it's
like you've got to be able to take some
feedback and sometimes it's about
training not training but like teaching
people hey
that person's allowed to have that
opinion you can ignore it you don't need
to take every piece of data in you don't
need to agree with everything but
everybody should and you need to also
make sure that the other end that how
that information's expressed has got to
be respectful
and not just be like oh you suck right
like something so in my eyes nothing
could be ever cool
right because what is cool like explain
to me what is what are you reacting to
what is the thing because
you can't say hey this guy's jacket make
it cool
like no no what is it what is the thing
that's like yeah very vague right or
this sucks nothing can never suck
um and you i won't accept it as feedback
like what is what is the thing that
you're saying what are the the problems
you have with it like is there some part
of this that's actually good and you
just don't like that part of it
and so one of the things that i think
with both that valve's processing
straight bombay is it's not efficient
because it can't be because efficiency
would be being blunt
in a horrible phrase radical candor
uh
it's in you you you don't want to be
blunt that way but you want to be you
want to be straightforward right and you
want to be compassionate with the the um
feedback you're giving
and then for when you get the feedback
you always want to assume the best
intention right this is where you get
bad where you're getting this problem
with bad fee with bad feedback i think
is when you assume this person's doing
this because they have an agenda but
they're trying to get rise out of me
they're gonna they're ignoring me but if
you say hey best intention this person's
giving me this feedback why are they
giving me this feedback it just goes a
long way
and yeah all that's hard doesn't always
work well sometimes it gets a little out
of hand um one of the things i think
i've gotten better at over the years um
so
where do you sit in that scale in terms
of
not taking things personally
if you had to rake yourself out of ten
oh i i you can yell at me you can scream
at me i don't care it just doesn't
bother me i grew up in that way there i
grew up in a household that was like
that right
okay well my mom's past i love my mom
but i mean like in seventh grade she's
like oh you're gonna be a failure you
don't know how to do anything it was
because my dresser drawer my dressers
had stuff on them and weren't a lot of
stuff on them it i knew she didn't mean
that i knew she was just trying to be
very clear with her uh information to me
um and it just made me laugh and i mean
all through my life i think people have
learned like yelling at me you will just
i have to choke back smiling i've been
yelled at by a cop once and i just
started laughing and he gets oh he's
livid
because that's my reaction it just makes
me laugh that i got you that mad it just
doesn't bother me um
so yeah but that said then as somebody
who now runs a company
i'm really finding out and realizing
that there's a blind spot i have right
so that if tensions are rising and even
if they're not expressing themselves by
yelling which is a really easy thing to
see
i don't
i'm not
perceptive to that other stuff it just
doesn't bother me
and so with that uh making sure that
other people are
protected as well and we talk about that
we make sure like some better
understanding like hey let's let's let's
have this conversation a different way
or let's take a little break from here
or if somebody wants to bail out of this
we can now and it's fine
um like i've gotten better at that
there's a really good book um
nonviolent communication
um that helps with kind of how you frame
about
how you frame about these conversations
that removes that and so if you're in a
place of power that you can do that
using some of those tools are really
helpful um and that's helped me as well
um but like the actual like being
negative feedback it really i just
always figure that it i'm sure it's my
fault and i screw up enough that you
know let's let's start there and figure
it out from there and i don't know i
know you were uh
deeply impacted by doom
when when you first played that game so
um um were you ever considering at some
point
going to bethesda or id software to
become a writer
or would want to wait so how do you know
i was deeply impacted by doom
because i read it somewhere or i heard
it in an interview possibly we uh well
we saw so when we first got doom we were
me and eric uh and a couple other guys
were working in a warehouse in um a very
rough neighborhood in cleveland which in
cleveland means something
um
and the whole rest of the business had
left and we got a case of beer
put it between us and then went back to
back all computers playing to the middle
of the night and we freaked ourselves
out to be scared to use the elevator
because
wow it was dark so it's really fun i
really like that but it's also just like
oh my god this is
that feeling in that experience of first
person shooter like that was the first
time i really had that like i had to use
the word visceral but you know like it
just really felt like in the game and in
the world and it was really interesting
to me and like why are these guys being
crucified i'm angry at you
whatever things i'm fighting i'm still
confused um but so like really like that
eric and i had at different points
thought of making games together and had
played around we'd live together um
and stuff and so that was always out
there and around there
but really
that kind of
feeling went for then to writing about
games a lot and kind of make you know
making jokes around games
and that was kind of a natural extension
i mean um
you know one point i moved down to new
orleans and i was a bartender there and
one of the great things about being a
bartender in a city like new orleans is
just a convention city
um because i was in the i was in the
quarter and so that means every week you
have a new group of people come by you
which means you can repeat yourself
because they've never heard it before
and you get really good at your pattern
your jokes and like we would actually do
magic tricks and stuff like we had a
whole bunch of stuff we could pull out
you can just do it every week because
you can get really good at your craft
because
it's new people have they haven't seen
it so when the internet first came
around
um i remember thinking now we can just
tell one joke and like millions of
people will come by so we just need one
really good joke
and if we have that we're good
um early internet days people weren't
sure how this is all gonna work okay um
so it wasn't that bad of an idea it was
like with that that we started then
writing about games and then realized oh
you got to keep updating
um
kind of you're pretty bad at updating um
but like that was that was that was the
idea that of just doing that and then it
wasn't really it really wasn't you know
until later that it was just like okay
this this could be a career this could
be something that we do
um
yeah but i mean i always thought about
it but never i mean
we grew up in cleveland there's not a
lot of
game development happening there right
it's even like when we started our
website it was like who's ever going to
listen to this is just two idiots from
cleveland screaming into the void right
yeah but did you
were you considering moving to another
city at any point were you like no i
love you too much here oh i in cleveland
i lived in a little village called
bratano which is north of cleveland um
which means it's right on lake erie we
had a beach we had giant bonfires when
swimming in the summer every day like no
i i lived a
pretty laid back life i remember telling
gabe like if i take this job that means
i have to put pants on every day like i
don't know
i was already working for myself like it
was a good life
yeah
well that's the thing because a lot of
people don't know that prior to game
development i mean you did obviously you
mentioned you're you were a bartender
but you did painting as well and you're
a data processor yeah at that point
owned a data processing company and was
doing um affiliate marketing
back when it was something small people
could do and wasn't overtaken by big
companies
yeah
so all those skills that you learned
were you able to transfer any of that
into game development
because
painting has nothing to do with game
development obviously
unless you're
painting something i guess
uh
like a pro
all of those all of those things i think
influence right so um
here for painting
i i quickly became a supervisor of
painting even though i don't know how to
paint
but i know how to communicate to the
customer
right and so then my team i'd be like
you guys do whatever you want i am never
going to get on your backs but the owner
of the paint company taught me one
really important thing
nobody knows a good paint job from a bad
paint job so
what you do is the very first day you
find out when those people are coming
home from work
because we attended these big giant rich
people's houses right so they're coming
home at five you stop painting at four
and you clean for an hour you stack all
of your
all of your drops all of your ladders
are perfectly lined up and stacked they
come in and you're not there and they
see that and they go oh these people
know what they're doing
because they have no way to judge the
paint they can tell if you got it on the
window but other than that they have no
idea if you're doing a good job or not
right
that's that's hilarious
which is then when you make a game what
you want to make sure is that people
the first thing that they're seeing when
they see your game is they see something
of like oh this is enough quality this
is enough value that i should go in i
think you're
doing a shitty job on the other side or
you're gonna play stuff later but it
always cemented him ahead of like you
have to make sure like people often
don't know and once you start playing
they know but like how do you express
that to somebody how do you express that
value of oh hey it's worth your time it
was easier at valve because everyone
would give valve's games a shot like for
now anna cruz is like we're starting
from zero which is both fun and
terrifying right but like those are the
kind of things i think about so like
every job has given me some value or
something right
you don't want to paint houses for a
living
why not
my dad does hard work oh there's a lot
of hot work i've done it's hard work man
people are good at it that's a real
skill yeah yeah it's hard work i also i
used to i
used to work at a company that we dug
ditches and
like literally dug ditches
like we would do waterproofing for homes
or lift up homes and move them like
physically the home put it on the back
of a truck and move it like those are
hard jobs man you do not want to be
doing those for a living well you end up
pretty jacked
from doing that sort of stuff
i'm trying to imagine you all jacked up
from
painting and no you're just tired he's
falling asleep all the time it's hard
work man i have total respect for like
i've done those i've poured cement
um like i had all those jobs through
college and
when people when we say talk about like
crunching on left 4 dead it's still not
as hard as sitting out on a 90 degree
day
digging some
trench
so that we can
lay some pipe down or something like
that was just brutally hard
so what was the the worst crunch that
you did then
because i've heard some horrible stories
over the years
i mean so left the left 4 dead was
pretty extended at the end there
um
the game
so
a lot of this is self-imposed to be to
be clear
like it's just my nature
um i'm getting better at it but like the
left for dead left for dead one was
longer than that there was a group of
people that were you know like six
months or something and crunch was
sometimes just like hey we're gonna work
tuesdays and thursday nights
um you know orange box was kind of like
that and then maybe towards the end it
would be a couple months of of more or
you know six days a week or something
um but you know it's
that was a lot of self-imposed i mean i
think the worst straight
like short burst was
i
i think i'd come back from russia
we were going to cert it was like i
worked a 16-hour day 16-hour day and i
still was jet lag and then we went to
cert and i remember driving home in my
car
on the freeway and being like hey
i'm in a car
i should probably pay attention i don't
remember how i got here
yeah
that was scary um but it was like that
but it's like it really was mainly
self-imposed kind of
um
really wanting to
nail that out and hit that and
it was
sometimes there's just dumb
grunt work you have to do and
sometimes it's more finesse when you're
in the more finesse you can't crunch
your way through it
right you can't it's really hard to be
really creative and really um
pulling in all those strands at once um
and crunching versus
hey we just need to play test the game
every day and make sure it's not
crashing like that's easier right
so has the culture
when you left but was the culture
relatively the same at valve from the
time you were there to the time you left
did it say oh no no they had gotten much
better they'd gotten much much much much
much better it's almost like hesitant to
ever talk about it and also because i
think i'm one of the people who
influenced the bad side of it
um no um it definitely had gotten much
better because if you if you think about
it as you know my early days there i
shipped a whole bunch of stuff and then
i didn't ship anything for a while
and it was during that period um that
also like uh
i think
the games of a ser games as a service
had really hidden home there and you
can't just crunch all the time there
because then you are literally just
crunching all the time
so structurally you need to think of a
better way to do it we also stopped
releasing retail retail is the curse
right because you're working on left 4
dead 2 and you're like yeah we're going
to ship this and game stop is like
hey when are you going to ship this and
you're like it's may i don't know
they're like well no we need to know the
exact day
uh right then you're like okay it's
gonna be november 18th the minute you do
that you've created crunch
right and so if you remove retail
release you remove that and so i think
that's one of the best changes for the
industry is so many people have just
jettisoned the retail release and it's
just made the world a lot better and so
that's why when you go over to like the
dota or cs go
or um even you know tf2 then was you
didn't have those retail releases
driving those you could be you know a
little bit better about how you did them
that's a very valid point though
um is there a particular reason why
valve has moved more i mean from gaming
because it seems like it's more about
steam and hardware and ar vr
is that just primarily because they just
see the technological changes within the
industry and where the industry's going
i can't speak for anybody else i can
speak for myself
so
i get done shipping
i don't think portal 2 is the last thing
that side we should i think there's some
dlc
oh definitely cs go
um so working on cs go
that's going to ship to me it's a clear
thing of like it's about competition
it's about a bunch of stuff there's not
i'm not interested the the work that
needs to be done for there is not that
interesting to me there's some other
projects that are going up and down but
they go up and down the source two's in
a weird spot not really ready for a full
first person shooter game
uh michael abrash and doug church come
up and be like hey
you should come down and check out the
vr stuff and at this point i'm driving
doug church home every day from work
just because then i could use the
commuter lane and even taking the ten
minutes out of the way to take him home
is still quicker
well i'm so like okay and then i see vr
there the the room vr for the first time
and there's like a second experience in
there it's these spindle trees that go
on forever
and i was just like wow
i'm like they're like there's like 30
minutes more to the demo i'm like yeah i
don't need to see 30 minutes more like i
just want to sit here for a while
and i was just thinking of like all the
times that we've tried to put the player
into the world how we've not been able
to do it in the way that i'm feeling
right now
this is before hands or anything else in
there it's just the view
and i'm like i am really in this world
in a way i've never been in this world
before
i've never been a big vr person
not a big technology person but i was
just like just moved
and so then um
before he left abraham was like talking
about like hey you know so we don't know
what we're quite doing yet with this
technology and how to think about it you
know do you want to
kind of come down and and
be that person for us help us figure
that out and help us talk to other
developers and just see what's going on
and i was like okay yeah this is really
cool i think you know i kind of want to
kind of want to see this there were some
ups and down there that happened
obviously abrash left
htc came on board
and then there's a point of that where
um
still really wasn't sure and then it
became clear with htc that there's gonna
be this opportunity to create something
that was
really special
and different and something i'd never
been a part of um and so
you know first
again i'm not a vr person so i literally
spent the first three months
on the team sitting in a corner watching
other people give demos and talk about
it and i just absorbed what they were
talking about and how they talked about
it and i remember inviting my wife in
i said hey i'm gonna go join this team
officially
and i'm gonna help launch this thing
i'm gonna have to be away from home for
a while for this like this is this is i
could tell like
i need to go out and find these people
that are gonna do the original demos and
all of that like i'm the person who
selected the or found the people that we
selected then to do the original set of
demos
and everything i'm like this is gonna be
you know i'm gonna this can be a lot of
travel again we talked about i've done
pr travel before we talked about not
doing that anymore
and you know she went through it and was
really moved by it and i said hey you
know the other thing is
this is this is a new platform and i
think we can define this platform
differently if we start differently and
so if you notice
the original demo that we did at gdc
there's no weapons in there there's no
violence in those
that was i purposely chose people who
didn't have that and do that because
that's easy enough to come later those
things will come later i had already
gotten to see an early version of like
arizona sunshine i knew all that would
come but here's an opportunity to launch
this platform and be something different
and so i took that so now at that point
alex is spinning up i could have gone
and worked on alex
or i could have helped launch vr and
work with outside developers and so to
me it was clear
i would never have an opportunity to
have this big of an impact
that i do right now helping vr launch
and working with those outside
developers and helping shape how we both
think about this and also the openness
of it so my whole thing was like we
always shared everything we shared
everything with the other hardware
developers um we shared them with from
sony to everybody i was always this open
here's what we're doing here's what's
going on never hide anything if you want
to see something we'll show it to you
i'll send headsets to everybody
i always try to introduce other people
to work with other people
um and just was always open and trying
to have that kind of influence on that
so
i didn't make a game that year to make a
game for a couple years but i did that
and i think for me that was a valid
choice to not make a game
right and so for my own personal choice
that's how i got there right
and for me
i i was happy with that choice at the
end of the day yeah yeah no that that's
fair enough and it's completely valid i
think that's a good thing
but you're obviously very in tune with
what's going on and technology is
changing all the time so how in the
world are you
keeping your finger on the pulse when
you
uh managing a company
you're working on a game
you have a family i suppose you have i
imagine you do have a life
so you've got to try and stay up with
all this stuff at the same time because
it's critical
yeah so for like the anachrosis we
decided okay this is the thing we're
going after like so it's about when
defining the goals of the game
early on and sticking with inside of
this like we weren't going to make
something in vr we were going to make
something that was a traditional um 3d
game we're going to make something that
let's say we maybe explore something in
the future but whatever but like but
like it's stop grab a bunch of pieces
and stop them from moving and just say
let's stop these from moving for a
minute and concentrate on this this is
what we can do
so this idea about being social and in
the online space has always been really
important to me
um
i'm older but yet grew up with this in a
way that a lot of people my age haven't
so they don't understand the like i have
friends that i've never met that have
only played games with
but they're my friends as much as
anybody else is my friend right
um and so like how do you how how do we
bring that forward and so that making
that the goal and making it devoid of
the
technology around it because you can
chasing to the technology is always a
nightmare
right
um but
leave that to other people i don't ever
want to make hardware again myself it's
really hard it's painful you can't
change it as much you can't iterate as
much
um so yeah
good answer good answer so with the
anachrosis because i know i never got to
wrap up so what's
what's the plan with this game in the
long run
so we launched it and the idea was to
launch it as rough as we could and still
get people to play it
because i wanted to do the thing where
you don't give lip service to um player
feedback but you actually get player
feedback and you actually build the game
based on that
now not in the crazy way of like i'm
gonna have some influencer tell me what
to do but instead actually have people
playing where you can collect the data
as well as have them play it
ends up were we too early on the two
rough
it was pretty rough uh it's crashing
there were some other problems like it
was clear if you yelled at me during
that like if you killed me during that
period i was like yeah fair enough man
fair enough right
i'm an adult i get it but equally a
bunch of people did play it and gave us
a bunch of feedback and now we're at the
point of like
the reviews positively people are
playing it the community is growing
um it's really fun it's in a really good
spot and now i want to do one last kind
of step with it and that's introduce
mods
so unlike in left 4 dead team i was the
person who worked with outside
developers there were making mods and
working with outside teams and making
mods and so i want to make sure that we
do that here and so it's embracing that
and so our next update that will come
out in june
um of mod kit for it as well as some of
the mods already being
built for it um
and yeah and go from there and it's
about because for me the social being
social and online
game isn't just about in the game but
it's about everything around the game so
it is about the mods it's about having
that new player experience with
something that your friend made or your
friend making some wacky
hat that you wear or whatever like right
and how do you allow that world to kind
of all interact and everybody play
together
and have a really fun place to play so
we started our discord discord.js
straight bombay uh and in there
um we don't just play our game we play
other games we play other co-op games we
play old source mods because it's like
kind of the two things right mods and
co-op games we just play them together
and we kick people out of there if
you're a jerk
and we're just like no this is just
gonna be this cool place we have like 5
000 people that you can just jump in and
play a game with not just our game but
any game and so then hey our game better
be able to work with that community
because they're like a bunch of good
people who like playing co-op games who
play games every week together right and
so like that's just a good test bed for
us and so now
um
now when i get now if there's negative
feedback about the game i'm i'm
i drill into it a little bit more
because i'm like kind of curious like
why isn't it landing because now i think
it should be now i think we're there now
i think the elements are there i mean
sure more content of course more
enemies of course more weapons of course
but i think the core of what's there is
solid and really good and so
yeah that's what we're building every
month ish we do a big update and then we
do a smaller update in between so
we did our fourth big update and just
did our
what eighth update overall um just this
week
so i i suppose the aim with it is to
turn it into this big big platform in
terms of as a
as a i don't want to use the word
service because it's not really yeah
there's a whole bunch of weird bad words
used around it yeah
it's just it's a fun world you want to
hang out with there's characters you
want to be there with that you like and
you get to play in a bunch of different
variety of things some of the stuff we
create some of the stuff the community
creates
but do you only want to focus on that or
at some point you kind of want to hand
it over to the community and let them do
do stuff and then you move on to
something else we want to expand that
with those yeah we want to expand out
what those mod tools are so they can do
more and more with that game
and then where that ends up is kind of
up to the community and we're really
open to that and then like you know
future whatever we do but right now the
whole team the whole company is just
dedicated on this and um if you go to
the discord you can see us it's just not
me jumping in and interacting with the
community but you know everybody on the
team does that yeah and it's fun because
then it really does feel like you're
doing something with the community and
you're really listening to feedback and
growing
valid valid um i know you've got to get
this is this is work time so i'll let
you go but um if anyone wants to keep up
to date with
you and
and the company what's the best place
for them to do that the best place to go
is discord dot gg slash stray bombay
um
then that's just discord.gigi and then
straight on base management together
i'll put the little description yeah
yeah that is that is the place where
most of communication is going or
hit me up on twitter my dms are open
it's just my name chathalsac or just
email me a chat at straight bombay i'm
always happy to chat with anybody i
always open to sit down and talk with
whoever
i appreciate it we do a very nice kind
of dude you do very nice conversations
with people
i appreciate it i appreciate that um
okay well that is the show everyone make
sure you share like and subscribe and
until next time stay safe
[Music]
you